Kim Kardashian explains those
interesting sinks in her bathroom guys
do you mind if I take a look around yeah
of course
great what's the most important thing
that you want your kids to know I want
my kids to be kind and to treat
everybody the same way but wait did you
notice those sinks vans first notice the
unique design after watching Kim's 73
questions with Bo so your home is
clearly stunning thank you how would you
describe this home I would say like a
minimal monastery but come on those
sinks are next level where does the
water even go well thankfully Kim
explained everything on her Instagram
story on Wednesday first let's respect
how cool this architecture is Kanye Axl
vibora and Claudio Sylvester in kind of
all did this sink and Claudia was the
one that's that it should be separated
from the wall because it used to be up
against the wall but we thought it would
be cooler this way now how exactly do
they work
it does actually like slightly sloped
down that you can kind of see and
there's a slit for the water high
pressures you want and no backsplash
will come up and wait there's more check
out these super chic light switches they
are just three little buttons and they
go on dim and off and let's be real you
know you've made it when your TV works
like this all right club
she wanted me to show you guys this
guy's oh my favorite person on the
screen it's hardly the first time we've
been fascinated by Kim's castle earlier
this month she opened up to et about her
enviable closet and collection of
sunglasses I imagine that there's a
sunglass Closet in Kim Kardashian's
house God well I just went to storage
and Kanye had the biggest sunglass
collection ever he used to wear
sunglasses all the time and I found his
whole collection and so I am gonna merge
that and I have to redo my sunglass
situation
[Applause]
[Music]